vladimir putin has issued a warning to
the west
insisting that any country that meddles
in russia's affairs
would live to regret their actions
putin's main political opponent alexei
navalny
who survived novichok poisoning last
year has been detained once again
on trumped-up charges he has just ended
a hunger strike of 24 days
russia had also recently deployed more
than 100 000 troops to the border with
ukraine
russia now says it will pull them back
but
it was a worrying reminder of 2014
when russia invaded and annexed crimea
what will be the impact of these actions
and how will the world respond
our experts answer your questions
what does navalny represent for russia
navalny since his return has gained
not just the statue as a politician he
basically moved from
reality from the realm of uh everyday
sort of politics
uh into the stuff of mythology and
fables
his captured imagination of the world
the uh
most famous actors writers poets are
signing
letters and on his behalf
demanding that he is allowed medical
care he has captured the imagination of
of young people both in russia
and outside how should america be
responding to what's going on
in russia
the u.s and other western countries are
having to think through potential
consequences not just
for navalny's treatment but also for a
host of other situations
in the past couple of weeks we have seen
for example a major military buildup on
ukraine's borders and so there are
potential consequences
for that we have seen uh the czech
republic
point to uh or blame russian military
intelligence
for an explosion that took place on that
country in 2014
and america of course in the past uh two
or three weeks
has also expelled russian diplomats it
has imposed sanctions on russia
for cyber activity a major cyber
espionage campaign
known as solar winds and all manner of
other kinds of russian
um policy and so i think the challenge
in thinking of consequences
is not only how do you send a signal
how do you calibrate these consequences
so for example if you use
all your sanctions now in response to
navalny what do you have left in reserve
if there is a russian
attack in eastern ukraine for instance
and i think the other challenge is
at least for the united states is that
although they want to send a tough
message they also want to hold out the
possibility
of dialogue i think that's the american
approach to this they don't want to
simply
squeeze russia or or impose a
punishing swinging costs on the regime
without leaving anything left for future
actions
do sanctions actually work if not
what other options are there i mean they
have worked in some ways whether they've
achieved what they were meant to achieve
as a different question
they worked in uh
certainly imposing a cost on russian
economy
making it more isolated
contributing to stagnation
whether they've deterred russia or if
they changed putin's behavior
i don't think they have at all
russia has shifted to different economic
model
after sanctions were imposed it became
much more of a sort of a siege
economy where the emphasis is on
protecting it from external shocks and
building reserves
on reducing debt uh rather than on
growth
so sanctions certainly have heard uh
but they to to my mind they were always
about
the west has to do something so let's do
that because we don't really have an
alternative but maybe shashank does
uh know sort of other more innovative
ways
i think one interesting thing we see in
the cyber domain
in response to russian cyber activity
whether that's espionage or disruptive
and destructive activity
in cyberspace has been naming and
shaming uh that is
um countries like the us the uk
and other europeans publicly laying out
the evidence
about what russian intelligence agencies
are doing in cyberspace
in ways that they never would have done
10 or 15 years ago they name and shame
not just intelligence agencies but
individual russian hackers
working for the svr or the gru or the
fsb
different russian intelligence agencies
and so that's a shift from big
punishing economic sanctions to targeted
individual
sanctions often against individual
intelligence officers or hackers
in ways that expose their activity
embarrass them and constrain their
behavior whether it has had
a substantial effect on russian behavior
perhaps that's too early to say
but i think it is shows it is indicative
of the evolving
apparatus of pressure on russia that the
west is developing
what was putin's aim in building up
troops on the ukrainian border
well between march and april russia
built up over a hundred thousand troops
on the border with ukraine
and in crimea to the south on april 22nd
russia's defense minister said
the routine exercise as he called it was
complete
and all the troops would be going home
as planned
now it wasn't a routine exercise we know
that this was the biggest buildup of
russian forces
on eastern ukraine and in crimea since
2014 which
is the year of course that russia
invaded ukraine in annexed
crimea so this was not routine this was
a very unusual
even an extraordinary build-up of forces
on a very large
and substantial scale matched by some
very
menacing rhetoric coming out of russia
what was the point of it all
well it's hard to say even western
intelligence agencies i think struggled
to understand
russian motivations and that was the
point russia was keeping its options
open
i think part of this was about russia's
domestic circumstances it was embattled
besieged at home with navalny in the
protests
it may also have been about a new
american president coming into office
joe biden changing american policy on
russia
in a much more robust direction so this
may have been a test
for the white house but above all i
think this was really an effort
to intimidate ukraine so this was
probably
an act of what what what the experts
call coercive diplomacy
muscle flexing intimidation against
ukraine in the hope of extracting
concessions
if that was the purpose it didn't
succeed we didn't actually see
any tangible concessions handed over
from ukraine to russia
and russia has returned home sent its
troops back to barracks
with a summit promised by joe biden but
very little else to show for it
what would happen if russia tries to
annex more of ukraine in the future
i think the response will be very severe
it looks for now as though the worst of
the military crisis
is over if we do indeed see russian
troops moving away from the border and
that is yet to be
uh yet to be evidenced we'll have to
wait and see if that does happen
i think the risk of a russian offensive
against ukraine has diminished
substantially
but if there was a substantial
escalation in the donbass if we did see
a russian effort to increase the
pressure there or if russia were to keep
its troops in place and to keep that
military threat
against ukraine and to use those forces
there's a limit to how far the west
is willing to support ukraine ukraine is
not a member of the nato alliance
but on the other hand there is a
recognition
that a a change in the status quo an
attack from crimea
an attack in eastern ukraine would
represent the biggest
crisis in european security for many
years and i think we would undoubtedly
see
a fresh round of sanctions against
russia it would it would prompt
a much tighter relationship between
ukraine and the west
and a pretty strong economic diplomatic
and even military response from from
europe and america
i'm shashank joshi defense editor at the
economist if you'd like to read more of
our russia coverage please click on the
link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe